USA soccer star what do you miss most
about it actually it's the people being
in that environment of such badass women
you know it's like being around those
women every day you're just held to
different standards you're your best
self or your fittest self um I miss my
body a little bit you know I think that
retire yeah of course return yourself go
sound what happened well I think that I
my body needed the recovery so I took
about a year and a half off of doing
anything physical yeah now I'm a runner
and I and I hate every step of it like
most people I like having had run so
when you're done after running a few
miles you don't like that feeling yes of
course I think that it's indicative to
of this the reason why I wanted to write
this book is because since retiring I
felt alone I felt lonely I travel still
a lot but I'm not with my friends I'm
not with my teammates and the whole idea
of working out by herself like I wonder
why it was such a it feels like such a
chore why do I hate it so much I used to
be literally a professional athlete
people used to pay me money to workout
and now I just I I suffer silently by
myself and so that's why I wanted to
write this book is you know life is
meant to be shared
both the suffering and the joys now the
full introduction you can get a copy of
Abby's new book Wolf Pack how to come
together unleash our power and change
the game online or wherever books are
sold
what's the reaction you get from women
girls well I think that this book it's
getting such a positive reaction because
it's giving women language to feelings
that we've had about the world that
we've lived in in our experience and in
the world for a long time you know I
talk about rules the ways certain ways
that we've lived these old rules and
then I kind of offer new new ideas and
new rules for for women to use and put
into their everyday life because even as
a Women's National Team player I
understand from the outside looking in
it's like oh well I can't do that I'm
not you but here's the deal this book is
for every woman every
and also I have an invitation at the
beginning of the book for the four men I
want men to be included because really
quality you know people use the word
feminism and and it really feminism
means just equality for both men and
women and and this is my attempt to try
to close that gap what I liked from a
you know father a parent perspective is
to understand my girls my daughters and
and while it might not apply to me but
it's also under in you know if you're a
parent and you have children who are
younger to understand what they may need
that you do not know and that's what I
thought was beneficial because you've
lived this life you've had these doubts
you had your ups and downs and to be
able to have your perspective can only
benefit me as a parent so that's the way
I was looking at the book reading the
book well I think that one of the more
important moments of my life is I found
myself on the SP stage you know me Kobe
and Payton all three of us we were
getting the same award this icon award
and I remember just feeling so grateful
standing on that stage a feeling and an
emotion many women are made to feel and
that feeling is the only one that we're
allowed to feel when I walked off stage
it was me Kobe and Payton I realized
like this anger kind of started to rise
in me and jealousy and envy in some ways
because all three of us were walking
into very different retirements and I
think that we can all understand exactly
what that means right there were walking
there hustling days were over mine were
just beginning I had to like literally
recreate myself and figure out what the
hell I wanted to do for the rest of my
life so that I can pay my mortgage right
not so you know and I'm friends with
Kobe and Payton I think that they
deserved every cent but so do I think
that the Women's National Team the
current team they deserve more than that
what they're getting okay but and
they're fighting for equal pay right now
why why is that an issue considering how
successful they are they're must-see TV
the men are they don't even make it well
here's the big argument that the men
that that happens is that a lot of
people think that the men's team brings
in more money so of course they deserve
more money well in 2015 the women's team
brought in six point six million dollars
and the men's team brought in only two
million dollars
so there goes that argument like we need
to move past this and then of course we
talk about this just being a
discrimination case which is true we
haven't even actually talked about the
women seem being the team that wins
championships right like and and I don't
want to like harp on and like rag on
these guys but they've never placed in
the top three of a world championship
and and our women's team wins Olympic
gold medals and wins World Cup
championships so when you're comparing
all of these things we aren't asking us
soccer the women aren't asking us soccer
to be paid more than the men we just
want equal treatment because what equal
treatment and equal pay means for the
women is respect and what that respect
means is a future of freedom and that's
what that's what they're working towards
and I'm really proud of them for it why
is it that whenever somebody's
successful a female we always want to
compare it how would you do against men
always like Serena great but what you do
again right you know a basketball player
you had it like oh yeah they're good but
you know could they even get on the the
pitch was with us what why do we do that
is that a subtle way and not so subtle
way of demeaning what the yes yes
absolutely it is it's a for-sure subtle
way of demeaning but like you have to
understand women have been operating
like this with all of these subtle
messages of feeling less than of you
know like think about the thing about
what you say to your son like if he
throws a ball or he runs like you're
running like a girl like really like
think about the messaging that you're
giving your son about what it means to
be a girl and how he's trying to drive
as far away from from being like a girl
because of that one comment we have to
be really specific about what we're
saying and the messages that were were
trying to teach our children both girls
and boys because the you know toxic
masculinity is a learned thing and and I
feel like because we try to compare
ourselves which is so stupid like why
are we why do we even need to compare
Serena Williams to a male tennis player
like she's like the best athlete of all
time like she's the most winning athlete
of all time like she's the best period
she happens to be a woman like it
doesn't matter if
you would do well against the boys or
the guys are not like she's just badass
by being sorry in a period well it's
like you that's why when I introduced
you you're the best soccer player in US
history it's not the best female soccer
player you're the best soccer player of
all time thank you and I would I would
say that there are many women you know
there was Mia Hamm and Alex Morgan now
so many women that came before me and
you know I want to give shoutouts to the
guys because they have also been a part
of the growth of the game in this
country I want them to be successful and
I want our men's national team to win
World Cups and to do really well you
know in Landon Donovan and Clint Dempsey
and these guys really grew the game here
in the United States which you're seeing
the the positive effect you're seeing
MLS teams and the the valuations of
those teams going through the growing
through the roof you know in Mia Hamm
she's a she's a minority owner of the LA
FC FC team which is just the dream come
true for for women there are not there
are not enough women sports franchise
owners in the world so I'm proud of her
for the the role she's taking and
obviously she was a fantastic player
herself you miss kicking ass
I miss competing I miss competing in a
way that my body was meant to move in a
way that I had trained my body to move
for so many years I mean think about it
like you spent three hours everyday
sitting in that chair talking I don't
know how the hell you do it
and and you are you are an expert at
what you do so it feels comes natural
and it feels comfortable well the last
three years all I've been doing is
things that don't come naturally to me
so I feel like I've been a fish out of
water in some ways in this transition
from playing to not playing trying to
figure out what I want to do with the
rest of my life and and I also just miss
like really pushing myself physically
speaking because I'm pushing myself in
many different ways now but physically
pushing myself and of course like the
bonus that it makes your body look much
better than it is now
now you were described as probably the
class clown in high school were you last
con well I think I think I was a class
clown that wasn't funny interestingly
enough
not like a jokey like I like making
jokes I like laughing but I don't think
that like I'm overarching leave
hysterical how do you become a clown if
you don't I just I'm always trying to
have fun and you know do the thing that
not many people would be doing to to
spark joy I think that you know not to
steal Murray condos like sparking joyful
philosophy here but I just want I always
want people to have a good time so yeah
and then a few other things here so are
you still dating as fan big time yeah
and you know I went to David I'm saying
no no no no no and I will not even try
so don't ask
can you sing some Dave Matthews for us
no oh okay crashing to me crush I mean I
loved going to his concerts we there was
always a concert in upstate New York
community I actually did meet him one
time with my then-boyfriend this is how
long ago and we actually we met him I
was backstage and he kissed me on the
cheek and I remember I told my boyfriend
that I you are not allowed to kiss me
anywhere tonight you know and little do
it little did I know then that there are
many other reasons for that when did you
come to that realization and how's that
conversation with your mom and I think
we discussed this before yeah I think
that I was in my teenage years when I
started to realize that I was trending
in a different way my my attractions
were were in different places than the
stereotypical kid and in the world and
you know I think that my relationship
with my mom is is far better than it
ever used to be for a long time I just
needed her to accept me I needed her to
say I love you because you're gay Abby
and the truth is is all I'm wanting is
her acceptance and that's actually all
she's wanting from me too so I've had
this like existential like understanding
and a deep healing that's been going on
over the last couple of years because
I've let go of needing her
her acceptance and just him offering her
full acceptance for her belief systems
because look we both want the same thing
from each other but because she was
brought up and raised in a totally
different time with totally different
values and totally different
perspectives like she can she come and
maybe meet me halfway for sure but like
I'm not gonna Bank the rest of my life
on whether my mom accepts me or my my
sexuality or not like I'm happy like
she's not a part of the the sexuality
sexual component in my relationship in
my marriage like we're all good here
and that's hard though when you get to
the point where you don't need your
parents acceptance like you and I don't
know if it means ok I've gotten to this
level of maturity or you know now I can
step away and I don't I guess you send a
message to your mom to say you raised me
well I I don't need that acceptance I am
firm on my own yeah and that's a hard
thing though
yeah I'm to that realization like wow
yeah and I'm growing up it's a little
terrifying for sure and I also think
that that's like a parent's dream right
like that's where that's where I hope my
kids will get to one day is like hey
thank you for all the life lessons like
I've got it from here and I'm and I'm
good how are you as a parent um I think
a really good parent actually I didn't
know how good I would be I didn't know
and my kids might have totally different
answers but I was actually just reading
this thing this morning that we parent
our kids in the ways that will heal the
traumas of our childhood
so my youngest child she's quite a lot
like me and her spirit and um and so I
sometimes notice myself because she she
shows me parts of who I am that I might
not necessarily you know things like
just being defiant and just like doing
what she wants that's not easy to be the
parent of a child like this right so I'm
trying to offer her a different view a
different vantage point than I was
offered not because I turned out wrong
like I feel like I I feel like my
parents did the very best that they
could and I really appreciate that but I
think that it
important that we don't try to parent
our children to become little versions
of ourselves like it's our job to kind
of be the bumpers for our children so
that they don't crash into walls all the
time have you watch your videos they
they do now they're onto Alex Morgan so
like I'm come on I'm completely
irrelevant like all parents become
irrelevant and and my access to the
national team my younger daughters they
play soccer so they think that my access
to Alex Morgan she came over to my house
a couple of months ago and I I rose to
the top of yeah mom's mom's cool for
tonight and then you know the next day
happened and I was just back to normal
the book is Wolf Pack and it's uh how to
come together unleash our power and
change the game it's always great to see
you I love our conversations same I wish
you the best in parenting and finding
whatever's next for you same for you and
you know getting your body back you are
still talking and you do this every day
is amazing but there's like pay you
based on how much you talk oh I hope
they pay us as a volunteer service this
is what I do
but as I told you when I get home I
don't speak and my wife thinks I'm a
great listener because I just don't want
to talk and I just say go ahead honey
I'm listening you have the perfect job
for creating the right kind of marriage
dynamic yeah yes I knew this job was
going to come in handy good job great to
see you thank you and thanks for having
worked for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]